Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
In past videos,
we've talked quite a bit about the Myers Briggs personality test and today we're
going to talk about the big five personality tests,
which actually psychologists have a tendency to prefer over the NBTI,
which looks floor here in a bit.
So the big five personality tests also known as the f f m five factor model.
This has measures five personality traits on a scale,
often abbreviated as ocean or canoe.
These traits are openness to experience conscientiousness,
extroversion,
agreeableness,
and neuroticism.
So let's go through and look at what these scales indicate.
Openness to experience.
The openness scale has to do with,
as you might expect,
things like being receptive to new ideas,
being creative,
being curious,
and handling variety and novelty.
Well,
and individuals who score high on this trade obviously exhibit these
aforementioned traits.
They're generally very open minded and maybe even more intelligence being able
to handle and actually actively seek out new concepts and experiences.
Very often,
lower scores tend to be more regimented and for lack of a more tact term,
closed minded.
Lower scores have their conceptions,
their opinions,
their modus operandi all in order and they're not quite as likely to divert from
it.
They enjoy more consistency and don't see much point in novelty.
Conscientiousness.
The conscientiousness scale has to do with trade such as diligence,
persistence,
organization,
work ethic,
thoroughness,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Higher scores tend to approach things more systematically than more often task
oriented.
They place greater emphasis on organization and are more focused on producing
results in the external world.
Lower scores,
however,
it may be a little bit less systematically efficient than may place.
Less emphasis on things like organization,
punctuality,
but are less likely than the high conscientious chorus to be conformist and are
generally more laid back.
Very high scores may be considered workaholics.
Very low scores may be impulsive and have trouble with organization
extroversion,
extroversion and its opposite.
Introversion is a fairly commonly understood concept of personality psychology
already.
People who score high on extroversion tend to be stimulated by social
interaction and external activity more than lower scores.
That doesn't necessarily mean that an extrovert is a better people person in
terms of social interaction.
That actually has to do more with art.
Next trade here,
just that they are more stimulated by social interaction.
If that makes sense.
Essentially higher scores prefer to act,
then reflect,
then act again while lower scores.
Introverts prefer to reflect,
then act,
then reflect again.
Higher scores may have a wide group of friends while lower scores may prefer
fewer,
more tightly knit.
Friend groups,
agreeableness I read on this has to do with traits such as empathy,
tolerance,
cooperation,
kindness,
trust,
things of that nature.
Higher scores tend to be more altruistic.
They have a genuine care for how others are feeling.
They enjoy the presence of people they like.
They may even take up positions of ensuring harmony within a friend group or
family or whatever and are quite skilled and working to achieve it and we'll
generally prefer to make decisions with reference to their own emotions and also
with consideration to the and harmony of others around them.
Lower scores are less empathetic,
they're less interested in emotions.
They prefer to make a savings,
which they believe are based on logic,
but what higher scores may see as callousness,
very low scores may even be somewhat selfish or generally like empathy for other
people.
And finally,
our last scale is neuroticism.
The neuroticism scale has to do with essentially your level of mental stability.
Higher scores tend to believe it or not be more neurotic.
They tend to experience negative emotions such as fear,
anxiety,
sadness and depression,
jealousy,
isolation,
anger and guilt.
More often and accordingly have higher likelihoods of having or developing a
mental disorder associated with these negative feelings.
Lower scores tend to be more mentally stable.
They tend to have more consistently positive emotions and are in more control of
their emotional state and disposition.
Generally,
they're more resilient to stressors,
whereas higher scores may be overwhelmed at times by external stressors or even
internal stressors.
So in essence,
that's what the big five personality test is a balance,
but it covers these five traits.
Scales actually encompass a considerable portion of a person's psychology and
are considerably reliable and consistent.
What you might have noticed if you've seen my NBTI videos,
is that most of these scales correlate with the Myers Briggs Dichotomy and union
functions.
I can go more into the exact correlation in the future if you guys would like,
but the point of my mentioning this is that a lot of these personality tests
tend to focus on very similar traits,
which is a key lesson and personality psychology.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.